Eighty percent of humanities papers are
not sighted once
so.
Well,
So let's just translate that for the
viewing public.
Yes.
That means that they're producing
scholarship that nobody looks at,
that even their friends don't
look out because.
Okay.
So what a citation is is I read
someone's paper and I find a good idea
in it.
And then I used that idea to buttress
and idea of my own or to,
or to,
or to riff off or to,
or to criticize even for that matter.
And then I cite them,
I say who they were and when they
published it.
And then the paper,
the,
that there's a huge bureaucracy that
keeps track of citations.
It's a major indication of academic
ability to be cited,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's the,
it's like it's academic payment to be
cited.
Okay.
So 80 percent of humanities papers don't
get cited once.
It's absolute failure is absolute
failure as a game.
If someone wanted to play a game,
uh,
I would suggest that they go and they
look at the publications of the
professors in a particular area and see
if the titles all sound the same and if
they all say something about
intersectionality,
a colonialism and,
and these other various social justice
words you might wonder,
am I going to get taught the same course
again and again by every professor in
this program because it seems to me that
all of their research is very similar.
Uh,
and,
and how can that be when there's such a
broad base of knowledge and the world
that we can have such similarity between
every publication,
which then goes on.
Why?
Why do I need to read my colleague stuff
when it's exactly like my own,
which,
which we see.
So just just as a baseline Jordan,
how,
like,
what,
what would you say is,
is someone who's doing some good
research?
What's,
how many citations would,
would they be receiving?
Maybe a collectively like what are we
looking at?
Thousands.
Thousands?
Yeah.
Well,
a good,
like if you,
if you write a good paper
then like a great paypal,
paypal will get you 100 citations,
right?
An outstanding overwhelmingly
outstanding paper.
I'll get you a thousand citations.
Um,
10 isn't none,
you know,
if you register with 10,
but zero is failure,
right?
It means your work had zero impact.
It means your work wasn't worth the
paper it was published on.
And this,
this brings us to a kind of interesting
little issue with regards to the rot in
the universities,
which,
which Deborah mccloud she says does not
exist.
It's like here's how the game works is
that we set up a little ideological
garden,
right?
The 10 of us play in and then we all
publish in the same journal and we peer
review each other's articles and we just
publish them.
There's no critique or very little.
So the,
the barrier for publication is very,
very low when it should be very high,
like a good journal,
a good journal reject.
Ninety percent of the papers that are,
uh,
that are,
are,
are submitted to it,
right?
So I'm rejection rates really matter.
So the question is why do the these
papers get published since no one reads
them and they have nothing to offer and
the answer to that,
and it's very straightforward.
The journals are extremely expensive,
are way more expensive than they should
be.
So just to buy a single paper online for
the ordinary person is like $40,
which is more than a hardcover book
that's just to download the PDF.
And so the journal itself,
the libraries are full of them,
are very expensive and the subscriptions
are very expensive.
And so what happens is the professors
pressure the university libraries to by
the journals and the library funds the
publisher and so the publishers will
publish anything.
Routledge is a good example of that,
much to my chagrin because they
published my first book but.
And they used to be a great publishing
house,
but they'll publish damn near anything.
And the reason for that is that the
libraries are forced to pay radically
inflated prices for the publications
that no one ever reads.
And so people right to publish in
journals that libraries have to purchase
at inflated prices to produce knowledge
that no one will ever read.
And that's the little scandal that
plagues the humanities.
I think it characterizes the humanities
more than plagues them.